of the Terry lectureship committee and
professor
and it's my pleasure today to welcome
you to the third of four lectures on
Jefferson and Darwin science and
religion in troubled times by our
distinguished Terry lecture professor
keith thompson in the first two lectures
professor Thompson gave us an intimate
and illuminating view of two of the
great thinkers of the late eighteenth
and early nineteenth centuries Thomas
Jefferson and Charles Darwin as they
struggled to resolve and if possible
reconcile their personal views of the
new scientific discoveries and the
religious beliefs made an interesting
story while we only have indirect
evidence of the inclinations and
motivations of Dwight Terry the founder
of these lectures I would venture to
suggest that he too struggled to put his
own thoughts into some consistent
consistent framework in the state gnam
statement of purpose which endowed these
lectures he said quote it is by building
on the truths of science and philosophy
into the structure of a broadened and
purifying religion through a series of
lectures to be given by men and I think
had he lived in our times he certainly
would have added and women eminent in
their respective departments on topics
which have an important bearing on the
subject all the great laws of nature
especially of evolution that mankind may
be helped to attain its highest possible
welfare and happiness upon this earth it
may have been discussions between
scientists and theologians such as we
will hear about today that mr. Terry
came to believe in the values of such
colloquy it was at a scientific meeting
in June 1860 at the Oxford University
Museum of Natural Science that the talks
that came to be known as the Oxford
evolution debate took place these talks
involved among others two famous
individuals Bishop Sam Hill so PCM
Wilberforce and Thomas Darwin's bulldog
Huxley sounds a bit like a pro wrestling
match doesn't it they faced off and a
critique of Darwin's evolution only
seven months after the publication of
the origin the debate is best remembered
today for a heated exchange
in which Wilberforce supposedly asked
Huxley whether it was through his
grandfather or his grandmother that he
claimed descent from the monkey
interestingly a historian of this event
said that in spite of this high
Victorian rhetoric afterwards everyone
enjoyed himself immensely and all went
cheerfully to dinner together afterwards
I would hope we could recapitulate a
little bit of that and I'd invite you
after the lecture to join us for a
reception just on the hall after the
lecture today's lecture I'm sure will
expose even more fireworks and is
entitled Apes and academics debates and
sermons and I'm very honored to
introduce to you professor keith
thompson for the third Terry lecture of
2012
thanks for well thank you very much so
I'm sorry about the hiatus between
lectures 2 and 3 i'm reminded of a
letter i got some years ago from an
undergraduate from franklin and marshall
college who wanted a copy of a paper
that I'd written and he wrote dear
professor Thompson I have just
discovered you are still alive so it's
such a pleasure to be back here to
continue these lectures and I want to
express my thanks really to the Terry
committee and also to loreley field in
the secretary's office big being so
flexible and accommodating and generous
dealing with my little problems so where
were we I was I set out to look at the
relationship between science and
religion which is always thought of as
being in conflict trying to find a
slightly new approach to this subject
with the hope that if you can find out
where the problems lie who might look at
them in a new way and this will we might
slowly get there by the end of the
fourth lecture my main thesis from the
beginning and I'll continue to is this
is that any such conflict like that
conflict between science and religion is
really only an example of a much wider
and more general phenomenon which is
what happens when anything new runs up
against any kind of convention authority
it certainly isn't confined to science
and religion and if we think of it as
part of a example of a general
phenomenon that helps a little too and
one of the attributes of this general
problem is that new knowledge and
authority always change at different
rates and authority almost always and
necessarily move slower than new ideas
accumulate doesn't always happen that
way but it but it mostly does now my
first to talk side I concentrated on
individuals because
it seems me very important that this
relationship between science and
religion is expressed first and felt
first and hardest by individuals as they
tackle the problem of learning something
for the new time and I gave the example
that interesting as the image of Galileo
before the tribunal might be think about
how fascinating it would be to be
sitting at his desk with him when he
started to read Copernicus and Kepler
for the first time and realized that his
whole worldview and everybody else's was
going to be thrown into disarray now
most people confronted with a challenge
like that might that put it on one side
for a little while some might choose to
deny it and some might choose to devise
some clever way of dealing with it of
the sort that we call saving the
phenomenon but it takes a brave soul to
tackle things head-on and my first talk
i talked about jefferson how he found
that his growing understanding of the
geological processes that shape the
earth became in conflict with the
theological notion that God had created
the earth all in one instant and in the
end he went with his religious view
rather than what he knew to be the case
from his own geological observations and
in my second talk I taught a little bit
about how Charles Darwin when it came to
the second edition of the origin of
species only a couple of months after
the first revised it so as to
accommodate religious opinion and then
as I said bitterly bitterly regretted
having done so now an interesting
question came up with the Origin of
Species very soon after it was published
was it a scientific work or theological
work it seems a silly question now but
what Darwin had had done in the origin
of the species was to demolish a pair of
theological points of view and so the
very famous preacher and professor of
theology at Oxford and man [ __ ] in a
sermon
doxford accused which was then published
in The Guardian accused Darwin of having
written this quasi theological work and
Darwin was furious and denied that he'd
written such a thing when of course
that's exactly what he had done we can
only guess that the reason why he was so
sure that he hadn't was that he his
arguments against these religious
theories which I'll come to very shortly
will all couched in scientific terms he
didn't enter the theological debate and
therefore he didn't think he'd written
the crazy theology but this question of
what is science and what is theology
continues to dog the issue through the
19th century as I will see so today I
want to describe the next stage in the
development of a major conflict like the
one between currently between science
and religion and that is when the ideas
that have been worked out among
individuals start to become slowly
incorporated in or denied by the
conventional authority and I'm going to
talk as bill said in part about the
Oxford debate of July the first eighteen
sixty on the third of July heated Darwin
received this letter and I'd like to
read it to you in part but this is only
part dear Darwin I've just come in from
our lot my last moonlight saunter around
Oxford and cannot go to bed without
indicted a few letters to you a few
lines to you my dear Darwin on Saturday
a paper of a Yankee donkey called Draper
on civilization according to Darwinian
hypotheses or some such title was being
read and it did not mend my temper
however hearing that soapy Sam was to
answer waited to hear the end the
meeting was so loud that large that they
had adjourned to the library which was
crammed with between 700 and a thousand
people for all the world was there to
hear Sam oxen that means Sam Bishop
Oxford well Sam oxen got up and spouted
half an hour with inimitable spirit
ugliness and emptiness and unfairness he
ridiculed you badly now you all saying
to yourself this written this letter was
written to darwin by thomas henry huxley
well sorry it wasn't it was written by
Joseph Hooker and one of this odd things
about the debate is that we think that
Huxley one very probably it was a
standoff but if anybody did win it was
Darwin's other disciple Joseph Hooker so
let's go on a little bit now this
meeting in Oxford in a museum of which i
was quite recently the director and
where i can assure you a thousand people
could not have got into the library
reading room although if they had no
wonder it was a heated debate and
literally as well as figuratively anyway
it would have been probably forgotten
completely her for one reason nobody
wrote down what was said except that
there was this pair of sentences that
bill has already told you that have
lived on in history partly because they
were remembered by Huxley 30 years later
when he wrote his autobiography as
something very rude was said about apes
and grandparents and Huxley replied very
rudely himself so let's just backtrack a
little bit you all know I'm sure that it
was nearly two years before the Oxford
debate July the 18th 1838 I mean 1858 so
two years not 68 that the naturalist
Alfred Russel Wallace wrote to Darwin
from the Moluccas and said I've had this
brilliant idea what do you think about
this and there was Darwin's idea that
he'd been working on for four to 20
years in a 20-page essay and it caused a
huge crisis and of health and everything
else of course as it always did with
with Darwin that was the 18th of June on
the July the first so exactly two years
before the Oxford debate
there was a meeting Howard meeting of
the Linnean Society in London of which
the to his with Alfred Russel Wallace
his paper and a paper hardly put
together by Darwin were red side by side
now here you would think this would have
been explosive not a bit of it one of
the dullest meetings ever held by the
Linnean Society for two reasons one well
31 people were preoccupied by the death
of the famous microscopist Brown of
Brownian motion and secondly the
audience only consists of 30 people most
of whom were Darwinian partisans and the
others probably didn't understand what
was explained to them there as just as
they say always about Darwin and
evolution just a theory no facts to back
it up and there had been lots of
theories on evolution before so this
first announcement was a real bit of a
dud in the next two years Darwin's ideas
started to sink in and then their
importance started to become realized
and whether or not it was crazy theology
it certainly was a huge challenge now as
you read any book about the early
history of evolutionary theory you'll
see that the de Oxford debate is the
great pivotal moment of the issue but in
fact by the time of the June meeting in
Oxford 1860 the discussion had been held
much more interestingly a more detailed
fashion in three separate debates no and
no less than our favorite place
cambridge massachusetts and the heroes
of the massachusetts debates or the
Boston debaters they usually call were
aiza gray professor of botany at Harvard
William Barton Rogers who was what a
geologist and founding professor at MIT
a couple of years later and Louis
Agassiz who was raised colleague as an
professor of zoology at Harvard gray and
Rogers had one thing in common
which is that they absolutely hated
Louie Agassiz and they resented the fact
that he had assumed the Pat the position
of preeminent naturalist in the Americas
north and south and also imagined
himself the greatest naturalist of the
world of his time and he was certainly a
great promoter he come over to Harvard
firms from Switzerland some years ago
and he was in the process of founding
his great legacy which is the Museum of
Comparative Zoology at Harvard where
many many many years ago I studied they
thought he was totally wrong and
allowing his wife to run a school for
girls in Cambridge Massachusetts the
school is now called Radcliffe College
but anything that Agassiz did gray and
Rogers were likely to be opposed to it
so let's just backtrack one more way
what Darwin had done in the origin of
species was to propose a theory which
had three parts one is that animals and
plants naturally very that this
variation is at least in part heritable
generation to generation to generation
and that life on earth is one constant
horrendous struggle for existence such
that if you have a hundred offspring or
if you are called two million likely
only one or two will survive to replace
you that is the element of his theory we
this the second thing is the what he did
was to destroy the notion that God had
created all of nature the natural
theology movement and that by studying
nature you could see the beauty purpose
and function the benign nature of the
universe and clearly if the earth was
ecology was as Darwin proposed one
constant warfare and
and if you try to explain things like
disease war and pestilence natural
theology didn't work very well and
Darwin really went at that point heavily
the second thing is the attack this
theory of special creation now there are
various views of how the earth how life
had arisen on earth there was the view
in Genesis that earth was created over a
number of days the life only on three of
those days there was a different
question was that it was all made
extinct anyway so the key question was
what happened after Noah and his ark we
populated the earth clerics and
scientists have sort of gotten together
in an uneasy compromise in which they
said well we'll just ignore that what we
will agree is that God created all life
on Earth at one instant we won't specify
when or where or how but this at this
creation of life on earth happened so
that it was all created in one place
exactly as it is now so that North
American plants and animals were fat
we've created in North America
aboriginals in Australia were created in
Australia in this flash this instant of
time and then you it was a way of saying
where you didn't really have to worry
about the any of the details just focus
concentrate on this theory of special
creation and Darwin destroy that theory
and that's the one that got him into
trouble for the quasi theology because
it was pretty clear after Darwin that
that theory of special creation was not
going to fly and if the evidence for it
came from what Darwin was very good at
which was being a naturalist for
instance why would God have made a
northern chickadee and a southern
chickadee on the east coast of the
United States when one chickadee would
certainly have done for chicka dienes
and indeed why are there all those there
family are called titmice why are there
all these other kinds of tits all over
the place there's the blue tit the great
tit the marsh tip long-tailed tit in
England alone why did why did God do all
that but he forgot to put the polar
bears in the Antarctic or to put
penguins in the Arctic there was no
pattern to this creation and no pattern
that could be explained by theologians
theologians or scientists it was just a
matter so well that's what happened and
the other side of this was why was it
that you could you could see that all
these birds like that the tip mice were
clearly related to each other and all
the woodpeckers were clearly related to
to each other and other birds like the
Hoopoe seemed not to be related to
anything why are these patterns they are
patterns in the mind of God but if they
were part of a result of a process then
patterns would be much more explainable
this is the way down was trying to lead
people's thinking so Agassiz was the
master of the special creation theory
the standard view was that for instance
if you took North America there had been
a certain seeding of animals and plants
in North America and then they could
spread until they ran into natural
barriers like the Rocky Mountains so
they wouldn't go the other side or they
wouldn't go to the east because of the
Atlantic and so on so that there was
some spread some migration and some
variation and taking that approach
scientists including Darwin's old
teacher Henslow at Cambridge had worked
out there were probably some 60 of these
centers where special creation had
occurred Agassiz didn't believe any of
that he didn't believe that there was
any migration that everything was
literally instantaneous that everything
was found exactly where it was now and
that actually made his view of special
creation rather rather vulnerable
he also thought that the that there was
no such thing as a variation I remember
I mentioned the beginning of Darwin's
ideas is is that organisms are very
naturally in that variation is heritable
in Agassiz view there was no variation
and this is this is one of the hardest
things to understand about Agassiz
because clearly everybody now knows that
there is tremendous amount of variation
in every almost every natural population
and the only way to approach it is that
you've got us no use thinking at it in
our Terms you've got to think of it in
the terms of the of the early 19th
century where it all looked where the
same data looked so very different and
that really to me it's one of the most
fascinating things about this but
Agassiz was convinced for instance that
the human races were not racist they
were separate species and Australian
species and African species Asian
species European species and and this
actually made him extremely popular with
the southern plantation class that was
very well represented at Harvard and I'm
looking desperately for a quote that oh
yes when he was lecturing in 1860 in
April while these debates that I'm going
to talk about in a minute were going on
a man called Edwin Sylvester Morse who
was a became a great evolutionist
himself and was very instrumental in
taking evolutionary theory to Japan
interestingly enough spence splendid
lecture by prof this morning that's
Agassiz on the observant absurdity of
believing that Adam and Eve were the
first created and the only ones it was a
masterly lecture and listened to with
great attention see the problem see the
intellectual problem you get into even
if there was a separate Adam and Eve for
the aboriginals of aboriginals in
Australia they still had to migrate to
fill up the continent
unless all the Aboriginal people were
founded at one time not descendants of
one ancestral pair so that as he worked
at his theory Agassi found himself
constantly bumping into conventional
Christian views having to do with
religious views having to say with Adam
and Eve so Agassi was a bit like
Jefferson and a bit like Darwin sort of
tremendously embattled within himself
with this theory that he wanted to
impose on everybody else and in a way
was a target sort of ripe for plucking
when Darwinism came along so what
actually happened in these debates well
aiza gray had travelled extensively in
Europe and met all the famous scientists
including young then a very young man
Joseph Hooker the botanist later became
director of queue at that time in 1830s
his father was the director of Kew
Gardens in London and he was very
familiar with the british scientists and
it 1855 got into conversation out
correspondence with Charles Darwin
Darwin wanted to know about variation in
animals and plants and gray was the
great expert on variation in plants and
their distribution over time so Darwin
was in the process of organizing a
little political support for himself so
that when he eventually launched his
theory on the world it wouldn't just
drop into a complete vacuum he would
have all the possible reviewers for
instance for the major magazines and
newspapers converted to his point of
view so he spent about five years from
1855 to 1860 being very political having
little political weekend dinner parties
at down house where he persuaded people
of his point a very concerted deliberate
and very sensible strategy for
launching on to the world such a radical
theory and he had sent a copy of his eye
is an outline of his ideas to a zoo gray
in 1857 so gray knew all about Darwinism
then and was certainly the first
American to know about it and one of
only say 20 people in the whole world
who knew what Darwin was thinking about
well this turned out to be quite useful
when Alfred Russel Wallace came up with
this idea and launched it dropped it on
Darwin's lap because Darwin need to be
able to show his own priority for this
idea and then he could turn to people
like a zoo gray and say well yes you see
professor gray had a copy of my theory
in 1857 so it all that all worked out
rather nicely but it also worked out
very well for gray himself because he
was in the process of becoming almost
sort of independently a Darwinian from
his own research he had been studying
the flora of Japan and in the in 1853 i
think it was he was given a huge
collection of plants that had been made
in Japan to study at Harvard and he
discovered something extraordinarily
interesting and he wrote a long memoir
it for the american academy of arts and
sciences which was published in 1859 and
includes and the last few pages a little
essay on how his discoveries supported a
Darwinian view of things and and vice
versa so what did he discovered he
discovered a remarkable fact about the
botany of japan and the southeast of the
united states and it's exactly the
opposite of what you would ever think
but there are lots and lots of species
of plants and trees particularly and
bushes herbs and whatnot that are in
common between the southeast like
georgia and japan and not found anywhere
else living in the united states
this is now known quite well to botanist
and gray was the one who discovered it
for instance you probably are familiar
with the the camellia family which is an
Asian family it has two representatives
l-3 actually in the south southeast
united states gordo Nia Stewart here and
Frank linea which of all three really
beautiful trees with a lovely scent for
those people who are genetically
disposed to be able to smell it I'm one
who cannot but these are camellias and
they're not found anywhere else in the
United States but they are found in East
and Asia so how are you to explain this
well it simply didn't work with the
theory of special creation if you think
about it either there had been one
Center which included Japan and South
East Asia I'm Southeast United States
but not the rest of the United States or
there have been two centers producing
the same species in both cases Agassi's
theory was up a gum tree and Agassiz was
very gray was very happy to point this
out so the first unveiling of Gray's
work was December the 18th I've December
the 10th 1858 so still 18 months before
the Oxford debate and he gave a talk at
the cambridge scientific club which met
in people's houses was a dining club and
he talked about Darwin's theory that had
been in the linnean society the meeting
and just like the linnean society
meeting it was a it was just flat no one
knew what to do with it agassiz was
present he didn't complain it was just
sort of there something too difficult to
deal with so then gray went to work and
December the 18th at the american
academy of arts and sciences this sounds
sounds very fine actually they were
meeting in his father-in-law's house
he started to present his work on the
Japanese botany and Southeast Asia and
it went on through the through the rest
of the at the spring into the early
summer and it was quite clear to
everybody that the evidence was
overwhelming that there was this
extraordinary distribution and grey
explained it in terms of the one thing
that could be most irritating to Agassi
which is in terms of glaciation now
Agassiz had burst on the world as a
scientist in 1837 why by his theory of
Jet glaciation which explained all the
evidence that previously people to
thought of was evidence of the Great
Flood all that sand gravel terminal
Marines and whatnot thought with water
yes but but ice and so the reason why
you have these things in Southeast
United States and in Japan is once you
had a coterminous distribution of plants
the glaciers came down and split the
whole area in two so these were now
relics and then the glaciers retreated
but they are still stuck as relics so he
actually used agassi's theory against
himself which was very clever and he
invoked there had to be lots and lots of
climate change which would go along with
the glaciation something else that that
the theory of special creation
explicitly denied so he was doing what
Darwin was going to do in the origin of
species but he did it much earlier in
the sense of attacking effectively the
theory of special creation so not much
happened then until the beginning of
eighteen sixty when copies of the Origin
of Species started to arrive in the
United States it was published in
October of 1859 so it didn't took six
weeks or so and people have got it and
now the american academy of arts and
sciences took the debate up all over
again and this time
the special creation people took the
offensive and put the darwinian on the
back foot leaving gray this time instead
of being leading the charge making it
very much of a rearguard discussion
defense of Darwinism when a remarkable
thing happened the chairman of the
meeting decided that it was possible to
make the special creation of Agassiz and
the natural selection of Darwin actually
fit together it wasn't so very difficult
it's it so this is this is a sort of the
Rosetta Stone of science and religion if
you like and in doing so he let the cat
out of the bag completely because this
was his groom up his concluding remark
if we suppose the time had come for a
dog to exist for the first time and
become the father of all dogs it is far
too easier to believe that he was born
of a wolf a fox aji hyena or a jackal
then that he suddenly flashed into
existence out of nothing or a few pounds
of chemical elements the very defender
of Agassiz had turned on me at the last
minute the next thing is that grey one
of the very important parts of a vagus
ease theory was that no species living
today existed before Pleistocene times
and this was the old argument about
human fossils of course than those days
there were no pre Pleistocene fossils no
pre-flood fossils and it was thought in
theory impossible that there that there
would be so all the fossil animals
belong to air I two elements of special
creation that had happened further and
further back in time exactly duplicating
the ones the last one that we we all
represent so grey and his botanist were
very it was very easy for them to show
that there were lots of species
living today that were present in the
Maya scene plants are much better at
this than animals are the pliocene and
to this tau agassiz really had no answer
the meeting was taken up at the boston
natural history society and now Agassiz
was on the offensive and he was saying
that Darwin's theory was contradicted by
the geological record and that's when
William Barton Rogers jumped on him that
this is this is really it's it I'm
making it sound as though it was rather
aggressive but it was all frightfully
refined and sitting around sipping
sherry in each other's living rooms
while this is going on so Agassiz had
thought that the great series of
sedimentary rocks of the Paleozoic of
the east in the united states have been
laying down in a deep sea and darwin
rogers and charles lyell all thought
that had been laid down at shallow sea
which subsided and rogers presented the
evidence and Agassiz agreed and for the
first time gave in to his critics by six
months from then he no longer talked
about evolution in any scientific works
though we tended to talk privately about
it he had been totally defeated by gray
and by Rogers it was quite remarkable
sitting quietly in these three sets of
meetings occurring in a period of about
18 months this is actually much more
exciting in a way although frightfully
dull than the Oxford meeting which was
very exciting but also no actually it'll
put that way rather Delbert somehow has
become exciting what's interesting is
that in all these debates Agassiz who
was defending the theological point of
view never once mentioned a theological
argument Gray who should have been the
anti theological type was a staunch
Presbyterian had a theological argument
go back again Darwin's theory is that
there is this variation which is
inherited and fought over in the
struggle for existence Gray had a
brilliant insight the variation is not
random but is directed by the Almighty
so then everybody's happy except that he
had said earlier why would we suppose
the Creator to do supernaturally that
which would naturally be affected by the
very instrumentalities that he has set
in motion that is if you set the laws of
matter in motion why interfere with it
at the very last minute why wouldn't the
special creation Theory be better a
stalemate but one that persisted for
almost the rest of the century in many
quarters the idea that you could make
everybody happy by assuming that the
variation was not random and it was
really only solved at the at the turn of
the century by the rediscovery of
genetics and mutation and so on so those
words of Gray's why should we suppose
the Creator to do supernaturally that
which he who's already set into
operation actually brings us back to
Oxford because at almost exactly the
same time as gray was with saying that
the same words were being uttered by the
professor of geometry at Oxford a man
named the Reverend baden-powell in this
case interest enough Baden is the first
name baden-powell the founder of
scouting was either his son or nephew
and they took the name as hyphenated but
his name was Professor pal professor be
power and baden-powell wrote this
wonderful book in 1859 called the order
of nature considered in reference to
claims of revelation in which he just
resolutely denied that there could
possibly be such a thing as miracles and
that if I may quote and this is before
he knows anything about Darwin
it is absurd to argue that the
introduction of new forms of life or new
species of organic beings in successive
epochs of the earth formation involves a
peculiar mysterious power or
supernatural creation merely because we
do not to present know the cause of life
or see the species arise before our eyes
which it may be added we could never
detect as such if they did and that if
you remember is one of the great
arguments against Darwinian evolution
that if it happens why don't we see
species evolving all the time and
baden-powell points out that you
probably wouldn't detect them if they
did so Darwin's theory as you can see by
this distinguished cleric mathematician
that Oxford from his right you see
Darwin's theory arrived in Britain at a
very very convenient time it was a
perfect time for Darwin at least he the
geologists had worked out the world was
extremely old and Darwin needed a great
deal of time for his natural selection
to work huge changes with very tiny
little differences in variation and the
Church of England had started to turn on
itself in a series of rending rending
debates over how much of this new
science should be incorporated in
teaching and in church dogma and
baden-powell was one of the people at
the head of this charge and two months
after the origin of species were
published this other book was published
which sold many more copies was much
more influential than the origin of
species and it was called essays and
reviews and I think I've referred to it
before and I will be referring to it
again essays and reviews was a series of
essays by seven clerics liberal although
they would have said moderate clerics
arguing for a revised way of you look of
looking at the way science in
it poses itself on conventional live
religious theory and in his essay in
essays and reviews after it's a year
after his first book baden-powell
becomes the first cleric in Britain to
endorse Darwin's theory directly but at
the time essays and reviews was much
more controversial because it had long
expositions of the way in which German
philosophers and philologists had shown
that the Bible and particular Genesis
was basically a series of fables rather
than a little account literally dictated
to Moses that it revolves to possibly
more with people now think for separate
literary traditions and that a lot great
deal depended on how you you translated
the words that in the English Bible are
down as made or created one could mean
made out of nothing created could mean
built out of something that already
existed these arguments were incredibly
difficult and argumentative in in in the
middle of the 19th century so this is a
long way long-winded way of saying is
that all this was going on just at the
time that Darwin's theory was published
and a heaven-sent opportunity came to
Bishop Samuel Wilberforce to cut all
this nonsense off of the knees and stop
it right there before it got any worse
the essays and reviews nonsense all that
liberal thinking and all this terrible
Darwinism stuff can be fixed because God
had given him as it were a tremendous
opportunity the university oxford
university had decided to build this
wonderful museum which was going to be a
secular temple to nature its guiding
spirit with the artist John Ruskin and
it is in fact you you have to go visit
the most extraordinary piece of Gothic
architecture with this incredible glass
roof which leaks when it's being fixed
it's leaked for 140 150 two years but as
we vary speak it's being fixed there was
going to do so the British Association
for the Advancement cyan't would have
its annual meeting at Oxford to
celebrate this wonderful building and
who would be the local chairman of the
british association meetings Sam
Wilberforce who had a first degree in
mathematics so it was no slouch and so
for several days everybody came to
Oxford and talked about the latest
research in science all over but hanging
over everything was Darwin's new theory
okay so there were 200 papers presented
at the the the the british association
meetings but the big deal was the
saturday morning i'm going to start with
the saturday morning then i have to go
back to the thursday before thursday
saturday morning a man called John
Draper a donkey vermin as hooker
described him he was a chemist he
translated Englishman who had taught it
was Professor chemistry at NYU and he
gave a long paper apparently rather too
long and not well-received at all
described as boring and dull but which
was essentially the invention of social
Darwinism and he described how the Civil
how europeans civilizations could be to
be analyzed as going through
evolutionary phases in their history and
he later wrote a long very interesting
book on the subject but it was extremely
badly received at the time which is
ironic because he later wrote this book
called history of the conflict between
religion and science which became the
book the most influential book in this
whole business of the conflict between
science and religion
of which the Oxford debate seems to be
such a pivotal pivotal moment anyway so
Draper gave his talk and Samuel
Wilberforce got up and decided to savage
Darwin essentially ignored Draper so he
launched into a great criticism of
Darwin and he may or may not have ended
by turning let us single out my friend
miles Oldman saying and tell us dr.
Huxley is it from your grandmother or
your grandfather's side that you claim
descent from an ape now if you think
about it could Bishop of Oxford actually
said that I mean it's amazing so Huxley
got up and Huxley was then not a very
good speaker in fact it was that debate
that made him learn how to be an
effective public speaker and he then
became Darwin's bulldog at this time
wasn't so good but he did say something
like he would rather be descended from
an ape then associated with a man who
used his great gifts to distort the
truth so translating this will because
said call called Huxley a son of a [ __ ]
and Huxley called him a liar it is that
really possible it doesn't seem right
for Victorian England and a Orion sub
maybe 400 people 300 of whom work were
clerics anyway in the mythic account of
this debate the evolutionists were
really ready for hubs for Wilbur cross
and Huxley was primed to go after him
that wasn't true at all he was going
home the day of the morning of the
meeting and he was persuaded at the last
minute to go because it was sort of his
duty to to go and listen to sam and see
if he could do something in the way of
damage control it was joseph hooker who
really thought that he had
one of their debate but since no one
wrote down what they said it's very
difficult to know who one who didn't win
what we what we do know from some
newspaper reports is that hugs the air
that will be else will befores went
through a rather pedestrian to us a
attack of Darwinism for instant pointing
out that there had been no evolution
because the Egyptian mummies and birds
that had been found we exactly the same
species as exists today and they were
the oldest things that you could imagine
especially if you thought the world was
only 6,000 years old but he did launch
into an attack on the great weakness of
Darwin's theory which is the business of
variation and hooker knew about greys
work and so he was able rather than
Huxley to attack that so this is what
I'm going to now read the continuation
of hookers letter to Darwin where is it
so so Sam oxen got up and spouted for
half an hour with inimitable spirit
ugliness and emptiness and unfairness
that were at that part of the letter he
ridiculed you badly and Huxley savagely
Huxley answered admirably and turned the
tables but he could not throw his voice
over so large and assembly nor command
the audience now I saw my advantage I
swore to myself I would smite that
Amalekite Sam hip and thigh and there
and then I smashed him among amid rounds
of applause Sam was shut up had not one
word to say in reply and the meeting was
dissolved forthwith leaving you Darwin
mastered the field after four hours
battle I have been congratulated and
thanks by the blackest coats and whitest
stocks in Oxford what hooker had done
was point out rather cleverly that well
because Wilberforce have been attacking
the wrong theory he had this is the one
thing we know from from a magazine
called the Athenaeum which gave an
account of
the debate a little bit of an account
the world before before apparently been
attacking jean-baptiste Lamarck
transmutation theory where whole species
were progressively turned into the next
species and the next species whereas
Darwin ate Darwinian Theory has
divergence from part of a species and so
on and so one of the ways that hook is
averaged Wilberforce was with to go
after him for having having gone after
the wrong theory so where did his
business of the monkey come from so it
turns out that on the Thursday afternoon
there had been a paper by Richard Owen
on the differences between the brains of
a man on a human and a gorilla and he
tried to present this as though the
gorilla brain and the human brain were
incredibly different from each other and
when he obviously knew that was not true
and Huxley certainly knew it was not
true and said so and they're a huge
route developed on the Thursday starting
with this and I like this one Huxley
saying he didn't want to once again
reluctant Huxley didn't want to get into
this because a general audience in which
sentiment would Julie interfere with
intellect was not the public before
which such as such a discussion should
be carried on and then he just tore owen
apart but in the process said something
like you know i'm not ashamed of the
fact that I'm descended from apes that's
why Wilberforce then could turn to him
say reminders professor Huxley but it's
the business about the grandmother on
the grandfather that bothers me so let
me just wrap this up fairly quickly
there are lots and lots of provincial
newspapers that cover the debate and
none of them mention a apes from
ancestors at all there is one letter
that went to the morning chronicle in
London and I will read you this
nothing has been so striking source or
nor so neatly pro proposed as the Bishop
of Oxford's question to mr. Huxley
whether in the yet sticky shaky state of
the law of development as laid down by
Darwin anyone can be so enamored of this
so-called law or hypothesis as to go
into jubilation for his
great-great-grandfather having been an
ape or gorilla so that sounds as though
it did happen but the Glasgow Herald of
all places has a different view the
Bishop of Oxford with all the
authoritarian dogmatism of the
episcopate denounced the idea that the
progress of organisms is determined by
law it was absurd although he allowed
that to any sensible man it was of
little consequence to himself whether
his grandfather might be called a monkey
or not so here's an entirely different
into the spin of this in the one case
you have a really nasty sarcastic attack
and the other one you have supercilious
indifference now of all the bishops of
Oxford that I have ever come across
supercilious indifference seems to be
much more likely than the sarcasm but in
the end we'll never know what was said
but if he really did say it then it is
certainly no surprise but lady Brewster
fainted lady Brewster is famous she
occurs nowhere else in history except
for fainting at the Oxford debate that
she was the wife of very famous
philosopher how sir david brewster so
sort of jokes aside the interesting
thing about one interesting thing about
this debate is and this has been raised
by historians of science was this a
debate about to the Oxford debate about
two kinds of science like the American
debates were or was it about two views
of a lot of theology a special creation
theory or the sort of deism that Darwin
was left with Darwin when you you leave
God as the original creative the earth
and then the creator of the laws which
then just ran like clockwork to run by
themselves theology or science it was
actually both because the core of it is
not than a series of appeals to
individual conscience or reason but to
Authority all the way through these
debates you are really having debates
about authority Agassi's authority gra
wanting to usurp his authority
Wilberforce defending the authority of
the church of england Huxley and hooker
trying to develop the defend the
authority of a new kind of science so
they make wonderful theater especially
because we don't know what was said the
theme is always Giants brought low by
bluster and dogmatism being overwhelmed
by new facts and logic but we shouldn't
have forget this immense personal side
that is in here this is where the
individual still appear in this process
of science and religion being in
conflict we're just seeing the process
of what individuals think becoming
translated into what authority takes
over so the debates can be seen as two
sets of weigh stations if you like in a
long and continual intellectual journal
journey in which religious authority was
replaced by a complex mixture of secular
non-scientific and scientific Authority
at first and specially after they will
be forced to blade nothing changed and
yet everything had and if nothing else
for one issue of profound importance
Darwin theorized and paleontologists
soon showed that man was not a special
creation but in fact descended from apes
Copernicus removed the earth from the
center of the universe Darwin gave
humans a pedigree and translated God
from being the special creator to the
giver only of the initial laws of matter
but it's important to remember that the
Darwinian revolution if you like arose
alongside an immense array of other
factors that can't be ignored
industrialization of society new
political economic and even legal
philosophies increases in every kind of
personal freedom startling discoveries
about the cosmos and with those came
whole movements in society evolved
involving change and that is what
evolution is about it is about change
and revolution against all kinds of
authority so these debates are a little
snapshot of what's going on throughout
society any everywhere when new
knowledge and new attitudes come into
old authorities territory what is not to
be questioned is it with each loss or
change or authority new doubts arose as
well as new certainties whatever
conflicts may have original persisted
between elements of science and religion
in say 1860 they were part of a much
wider picture of change and in the
process of change both religion and
science have had to think seriously
about what their new roles should be
perhaps not enough and that's what we'll
talk about in the next lecture thank
for those of you who would like to ask
questions we have two microphones here
so the rest of us can hear which is you
have to say and ask hello that was
wonderful um two things it's my
impression that the idea of evolution
had been around for some time yes
Darwin's own grandfather had written of
it and the significant thing was the
idea of natural selection that's correct
you're not evolution but evolution by
natural selection that's absolutely
right Darwin's grandfather was well it's
actually goes back to classical times
the notion things might be related by
descent Erasmus Darwin was the first to
propose it and he actually also proposed
the notion that artificial selection
animal and prompt plant breeding would
be a model for this and that's the first
item that Darwin copied into his first
notebook on transmutation as he calls it
but yes and and that is I think that's
why when the in both a in the linnean
society and in the upper right of the
cambridge scientific society meetings it
didn't cause a great sensation because
now that always people thinking about
ideas of solution that the trick is to
persuade me that any one of them might
be true and so it wasn't till the book
came out that there was any real
necessity to take this particularly
seriously but you touch on another point
which i think is interesting we tend to
say evolution or sometimes evolution as
a synonym for natural selection and that
is that is quite incorrect Darwinian the
wood Darwinian theory of evolution is a
theory of natural selection or evolution
by natural or evolution by chance yes
there are
means there's artificial exact actual
yada yada yada yeah yes so the other
thing is I think there's always a misuse
of it's only a theory hypothesis is
something for which there is no evidence
and you have an idea yeah and then you
do some experiments yeah theory is what
we all do in the laboratory here
ninety-nine percent of the scientific
work today deals with theories where we
have some ideas we have some data and
we're trying to sharpen up our idea of
what we think it is hardly ever a law
we're always we're always polishing up
our ideas yeah I don't think that I
think that's a misuse of those words
it's it's it's just it's grown up since
the 1860s but there was a nice article
in the new york times by think Nicholas
Wade was a Nicholas way through on this
very point Einstein's theory of
relativity is is a theory constantly
tested Agassi's theory of glacial
glacial action was a theory I mean it's
just it's one of these locutions that
that's developed but has left the whole
subject open to criticism because it
seems like a weakness where as we know
it's just that's the way it is in the
scientific world because everything is
in the end falsifiable at some point or
other and then and we've made it much
worse because there's another locution
which is just as bad which is you people
say they believe in evolution yep when
it means they accept they understand or
they follow but to say they believe in
evolution or to say they believe in the
theory village evolution it's so which
it wishy-washy is I mean what should
they say they should say they accept
well they work with or they understand
but basically you say I accept
so I'm not all the way over with Dawkins
but I would often say to people on the
other side the hypothesis of God the
hypothesis well as you said that there's
the difference between the hypothesis
and the theory is is no evidence it is
amazing and and I sure you know a great
example of that is the Pope originally I
mean in this we can say this century
shows how old I am in the last 50 years
has allowed that the theory of evolution
is to be considered a that the natural
selection is to be considered a theory
and no longer hug and hypothesis a very
distinct difference that was made by the
Catholic Church which is a very
important one for science the difference
between a hypothesis in the theories is
essential could you remind this for how
he changed the last sentence or two or
between the additions oh yes well to get
it right I'll actually find it for you
so the question is what did Darwin
actually due to the origin of species at
the very last minute sorry you
okay so you have to remember ah the the
last paragraph of the origin of species
is one of the most glorious pieces of
writing in scientific writing thus from
the war of nature from famine and death
see there there's the snide remark about
natural theology right there thus from
the war of nature from famine and death
the most exalted object which we are
capable of conceiving namely the
production of higher animals directly
follows there is grandeur in this view
of life with its several powers having
been originally breathed into a few
forms or into one and that while this
planet has gone cycling on according to
the ficks law of gravity from so simple
the beginning endless forms so beautiful
and most wonderful most beautiful
actually and most wonderful have been
and are being evolved the key phrase is
there is a grandeur in this view of life
originally breathed into a few forms or
one and Darwin changed it this view of
life with its several powers having been
originally breathed by the Creator into
a few forms or one it's one of those
things like so often it seems so simple
and and unimportant and he bitterly
resented having given in to the pressure
most most of probably most severely felt
in his household because his wife was
such an ardent believer and you can just
see him saying well it's no no this
there's no harm there's no harm in
business so let's do it and then saying
ah what have I done it looked like it's
like Galileo reading Copernicus it
backwards is that
anyway yes this is other other questions
before we go and get a yes oh um you
have mostly a comment using your own
chronology with Jefferson as a physical
scientist and Darwin as a biological
science it seems that initially this the
schism between religion and Western
religion i guess and science is more of
a physical science not able to come to
terms physical science and then you get
into biological science a much more
severe schism that we still to this day
we cannot repair easy to say things are
pushed around by glaciers etc and then
then and say that well humans came from
the supreme beings came from yeah I'd
say I disagree I'm it the timing is the
timing is such it's a bit like the the
view of how the science is developed the
physical sciences then the network's
physics chemistry biology last because
it's its most difficult but I think if
we were around in the 17th century we
would not have thought that the
biological problems were and could check
though that we would think the problems
with biology today were any more severe
than the problems with cosmology then I
I really don't I really don't think so
but I do think they're they're exactly
the same class a class of problem and
it's the problem becomes acute when you
when enough new knowledge is able to
really make a dent in the authority that
it bumps into and the science is
developed in this strange sequential way
so the next the question will be what is
the next one that's going to cause a
huge crash in the in the intellectual
world in it
has something to do with dark energy i
think but not in my time anyway exactly
what i'd like to do is separate religion
from from what the bible says because
religion everybody you cannot change
what people believe what they think all
you can do is maybe show them something
and they have to make the change but i
think when we look at the Bible you
mentioned the earthwork was created in
some days the Bible says in the
beginning in Genesis God created the
heavens and the earth doesn't say when
that was a million billion trillion
years ago but when it starts separating
the light from the darkness and the
waters from the waters each day it says
there came to be an evening the came to
vm warning their first day they came to
be an evening a morning a second day all
the way up to the sixth day it says
there came to be an evening became teva
morning the sixth day that God proceeded
to rest on the seventh day and we read
from other scriptures that God is still
resting thousands of years later and it
talks about some that will enter into
that rest so we can see also when it
talks about the six days it says this is
the history of the heavens and the earth
in the day what God created them so we
can see that's not 24 hours it's a
period of time and most likely
separating light from the darkness was
six or seven thousand years in length
that didn't do it like that just like
when we do want to re is that here we
don't turn the lights on and off and
separating the waters so we look at it
that way and we start examining the
Bible we come to find that it is an
agreement with proved science
even going to the moon we had to know
that within our atmosphere there's a
temperature range of around 3,000
degrees Fahrenheit and we all know what
happened to one of the spacecraft's
coming back when it wasn't insulated
properly and we started looking what the
Bible says talks about this when he
could separated the waters from the
waters above the earth came to be this
expanse and be no blow the earth came to
be the Seas and when we start examining
these things we come to find that the
Bible is an agreement with proved
science not what religion says oh so
this is a debate that was held in huge
detail in in the between 1800 1900
really and this is what they that the
major essay in essays and reviews
attacked because the German philologists
had looked very carefully at what the
Bible says and what it could mean and
you're certainly right one of the things
that everybody agreed on very early was
that it didn't preclude there having
been immense period of time before God
created thee because of the word created
if he created it out of nothing then the
instant he created it that's when time
began if we created it out of something
then there could be an immense period of
time before that and people have spent a
long time trying to match up the timing
of the first chapter of Genesis with the
geological record for instance the three
days of Korea when life is actually
created for years was was tried to match
up with the paleo of the Mesozoic and
the scene is eric errors but it never
it's never fully satisfying to people
because you for instance have the
creeping things before the plants which
they would certainly have eaten you have
the
I forgotten what the wording is and but
anyway you finish up with light and dark
before the creation of the Sun and and
and there was there are so many
inconsistencies that you have to ask
yourself what are we trying to
accomplish here are we trying to show
that what is written in the book of
Genesis and particularly as translated
in the King James Version are we trying
to show that that is the literal truth
of something or we're trying to show
that it is a remarkable folk history of
what we now know to be from from all the
science and everything I mean if you
look at it that way essentially it's a
remarkable document Genesis because it
doesn't say for instance that there were
humans before the Sun and the moon were
made and whatnot so but it's like all
the other folk histories of creation
their creation myths of the Navajo or
the Aboriginal Australian Aboriginals
with the Dreamtime and whatnot if you
want to make it literally dictated by
God to Moses then the internal
consistencies destroy it if you want to
if one I don't mean you personally but
be right but I'm if one wants to make it
a fascinating account of a fascinating
putting together of a story what might
have happened that has turned out to be
really quite interesting in terms of
sequences sequentiality then then it's
yeah it's it's quite fun and there is
absolutely no limit to the amount of
time that can be spent debating the
finest points of each word of the king
james version particularly because you
you really have to do the hebrew first
but thank you for your point I I it's
very interesting but i think i will
exert a limit on this discussion okay
and ask you all to adjourn with us to
the
room at the end of the hall and continue
the informal discussions thank you